bone broth and celery juice
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's wedding today youtube review is
going to be short and sweet
i'm going to be taking it back to the
early days of these reviews which
i guess were simpler times partially
because i met mentally stretched
crazy thin with two kids and a business
in kova times
and partially because you have asked me
to review these harper
bazaar videos so much that i figured
it was a good time but also i don't know
i guess i just generally feel a little
less permissive towards
massive super celebs who have massive
budgets
and massive pr agencies vetting their
every move
compared to everyday youtubers who are
just exploring
who they are through food but of course
as always
i do plan to keep this super respectful
so i ask that you all do the same in the
comments
now to kick this sub series off we're
going to start with
everyone's favorite frenemy kylie jenner
now if you don't know who kylie is
i don't know type ky into google and it
will probably come up
as the first suggested search the girl
is
that big now before we get into it of
course a few disclaimers
the information in this video is for
educational and entertainment purposes
only
so you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
healthcare needs
obviously this format follows a
celebrity's description of what they eat
so i know very little about its accuracy
portions brands cooking preparation etc
so
i will be making some pretty broad
assessments
a trigger warning to any of those with
disordered eating tendencies
i am going to be critiquing meals based
on their nutrient merit alone because
that is all i have to go on but that
says nothing about their overall value
so feel free to skip this video if it's
not supportive of your recovery
bone broth it's mixed with like lavender
and lemon
or my celery juice so i have like a
whole drawer in my refrigerator of just
raw celery so i will juice it of course
you have an entire
celery fridge drawer yeah so let's talk
about bone broth
okay so i get that this is a super
nutritious food
but i just can't get into the whole
concentrated flavor of meat
first thing in the morning thing not for
me
but in case you haven't already hopped
on the bone broth bandwagon
let me tell you why it's so hot
mom jokes they are just i'm out of here
anyways so bone broth is made by
simmering animal bones and water and
vinegar to extract nutrients
like calcium magnesium potassium
phosphorus and more
from said bones bone broth is also rich
in collagen
which if you wanted my thoughts on
whether or not this alleged super
nutrient actually does
anything for your hair nails and skin
you can check out my video
right here now the other super trendy
component of bone broth is gelatin
which broth enthusiasts believe can
magically heal your gut
unfortunately while we have some early
rat research on the role of gelatin in
healing the digestive tract's mucosal
lining
we don't really know if it does that
much in humans
we do however have human research on its
role in joint health
with one study on 60 people with
rheumatoid arthritis achieving
significant symptom improvements
after just three months of use but i
don't know
something tells me that joint pain is
not really kylie's concern
a more likely incentive especially since
later on in the video kylie describes
drinking
two liters of the stuff a day is the
fact that bone broth is
super low in calories and rich in
gelatin protein
which research suggests specifically
does increase the sensation of
fullness now most brands of bone broth
have around 50 calories
and 10 grams of protein per cup which
i must say is pretty much a dieter's
dream
minus the fact that it tastes like well
broth but in short thanks to medical
medium
who's a psychic not a dietitian by the
way
celery has become the cure-all to legit
every ailment under the sun this medium
anthony williams claims that celery
juice contains
undissolved cluster salts which rebuild
hydrochloric acid in the stomach
binds to the toxins and flushes them out
he also says that celery juice
strengthens bile
which is needed for digestion to help
kill off disease
but bile has nothing to do with celery
or cluster salt
so yeah it's all total bs
as for its alleged weight loss benefits
well celery has like
five calories of stock so a glass
of the stuff is basically just slightly
flavored slightly colored water
obviously we know that consuming any
fruits and vegetables
have benefits so i love seeing veggies
consumed in the morning
but part of the major benefit of produce
is the fiber
and when we juice celery we lose out on
that
so i say drink your water eat your
celery
and fill that extra fridge drawer with
something like
anything else okay next no food yet but
we have more
beverages and kylie talks about having
her tea
or her go-to coffee drink which was an
iced vanilla oat milk latte
and that's cool you know i have a kind
of review rule that i try to follow
that is i don't critique people's coffee
order
oat milk almond milk regular milk no
milk sugar stevia
i don't care i i just believe that it's
unsustainable to tell people to switch
up
something as ritualistic as their coffee
stormy and i usually eat breakfast
together she likes
fruit blueberries she loves turkey bacon
oh she loves bagels so i'm just noticing
the language
stormy likes this stormy likes that what
does kylie like i mean
does kylie eat these things too or are
we still kind of full from all that
broth and juice
probably the most important thing that
you can do to raise
a competent eater is to model good
eating behaviors yourself
and that starts with family meals as for
the meal itself
i don't know if she eats all of these
things together but if breakfast
was theoretically blueberries turkey
bacon and
bagels okay like that's a relatively
balanced meal right there
we've got some carbs from the bagels and
berries and protein in the bacon
yes i know i say bagel's weird so don't
troll me but i would probably aim to
choose a whole grain bread
most days or use the bagel as a vehicle
for some kind of nutritious spread
like avocado or chia jam ricotta or a
nut or seed butter
as for the turkey bacon i do have some
thoughts i mean i think it's totally
fine
in moderation and if it's a religious
choice to avoid pork
then by all means like turkey is a fine
replacement sometimes you just want that
bacony flavor
but i do think that a lot of people
choose turkey bacon specifically
thinking that it's a healthier more diet
friendly alternative to traditional
pork bacon but i do believe that this is
mainly just a lot of health washing and
really good marketing
yes turkey bacon has about 25 fewer
calories per ounce compared to regular
pork bacon
but they have virtually the same amount
of sodium
and depending on the brand you'll likely
end up with
less protein in the turkey now
i am not saying that either of these are
health foods
and depending on your health priorities
and goals turkey may still be
a better choice but i just call this out
so that people don't unnecessarily
demonize regular bacon while granting
turkey bacon
the green light to eat all day air day
both of these are fine choices so choose
your favorite
and enjoy it in moderation i can't eat
the same thing every day
definitely happy to hear that kylie says
she doesn't eat the same thing every day
i mean i know that's really common in
the dieting world
to stick to a small selection of foods
and eat pretty much the same thing every
day
i've seen it a lot in my reviews makeup
shayla
but yeah variety is the spice of life
and not just for emotional and
personal fulfillment purposes but also
for nutrition as well
when we limit ourselves to a handful of
safe foods or safe meals
even if these are really nutritious
meals we miss out on getting a wide
range of phytonutrients
and antioxidants not to mention even if
your macros look good or
even perfect by some online calculators
standards
a lot of nutrients work in mysterious
symbiotic ways together and you would
never
ever be able to achieve that on a really
narrow diet as for said varied meals
kylie talks a lot about loving lemon
chicken with
rice and kale salad and i originally
thought of lemon chicken like the
american chinese food that i used to eat
as a kid
but thankfully her instagram had a story
highlight
that explained to me that it's basically
more like
seasoned pan-fried chicken pieces
simmered in
a lemon brothy sauce which definitely
will bring in that delicious
lean protein and then combined with the
carbs in the rice
and lots of fiber rich veggies in a kale
salad
it sounds like an awesome balanced meal
she also talked about doing like a
mexican themed meal one day
with a burrito some rice on the side and
enchiladas
i'm not sure if that all was just for
her or
if she was simply like ordering for a
group and sampling with friends
but i would say that having those three
items together
would be a lot of the same same stuff
you know we got
we got carbs in the burrito tortilla and
the enchilada tortillas
plus we've got carbs and rice in the
burrito and on the side
we got protein in the steak burrito and
in the enchilada and then
fat in what i assume is probably a lot
of cheese on top
hopefully there's some guacamole in
there to like get a little bit of
fiber-rich produce but if not
my suggestion would be to go for either
the burrito or the enchiladas and rice
and then add a salad on the side
the last suggestion was the salads and
tuna sandwiches from healthnut in la
all of which look absolutely amazing
i total wanderlust when i googled their
menu and like
dreamt of the la trip that i had to
cancel in april
of this year thanks kelvin but i love
that i'm seeing
lots of options on the menu with a nice
balance of veggies
fat protein and fiber rich carbs i mean
the high protein salad looks
totally my jam or the tofu salad for
those who don't eat meat
also loving that the tuna sandwich that
she mentioned is served with greens on
the side
so we've got some perfectly balanced and
probably
really satiating meals my favorite
cheap meal is probably i want to say in
and out
there it is my favorite phrase
cheat meals i'm not going to start a
rant about why i'm not a fan of this
concept so let's just stick to said meal
but i have to say i'm also a huge fan of
in-n-out
my personal order would be like an
animal style burger with banana peppers
and a root beer float
kylie says that her order is a double
cheeseburger
special sauce and grilled onions
sometimes protein style depending on the
mood sometimes not
fries and a coke solid i respect that
the girl sometimes goes like classic
devil cheeseburger
with the bun and then sometimes wants it
without the bun
depending on her mood this shows some
flexibility
and that her cheat day doesn't have to
be like an
all-out binge on everything and anything
that she
otherwise wouldn't allow herself in a
week but or not
for a cheat meal this isn't outrageous
this
isn't a 10 000 calorie mukbang eating
challenge
where an influencer eats an entire box
of donuts just
for their first meal of 10 meals that
day
it's a normal meal it's not particularly
rich in antioxidants
or fiber and yes it's high in salt and
sugar and fat
but if this is how kylie cheats i mean
i don't really see anything wrong with
that other than the fact that she
considers it a cheat
okay moving on to snacks kylie's choice
in snacks is
definitely eclectic she likes barbecue
lays
doritos goldfish pomegranate seeds
miso soup apparently she gets liters of
it and
also the same broth that she has for
breakfast
i would say with the exception of the
pomegranate arils which
are rich in antioxidants and fiber i
mean it's got
a whopping seven grams of fiber per cup
her snack choices are pretty high in
salt
so a cup of miso soup has less than 100
calories
but it has 34 of your sodium needs for
the day
that means that a liter of the stuff
will put you
well above your salt targets for the day
and
probably leave you feeling pretty
bloated obviously we know that doritos
and lace chips are going to be high in
salts and saturated fat
but even goldfish which are often touted
as a good option for kids
have 11 of your sodium needs in one
serving
so no shame in enjoying goldfish
crackers i love them or even giving them
to your kids
my kid loves them but to make that snack
a little bit more balanced
i would pair the salty crackers or chips
with a piece of potassium-rich fruit
to help balance that sodium out and if
you want to learn a little bit more
about the relationship between salt
and potassium definitely watch my
nicocado avocado video
right here what else is going on i
am either cooking
probably for stormy or
and myself or girl don't make your own
nutrition an afterthought i get it
though as a busy mom who wants their
kids to eat well
i get that it's totally second nature to
put our kids first
in every area of life and that often
means feeding our kids
before ourselves but when it comes to
food and meals
like i said eating with our littles and
eating the same things
as our kids is actually one of the best
things that we can do for them
the evidence is so clear that family
meals have a wide range of physical
and mental health benefits like better
academic performance
self-esteem and lower risk of depression
eating disorders
obesity and more but it's also one of
the most important and easiest ways
to raise a competent eater so again if
you're looking for
more tips on dealing with picky eating
check out my video
right here as for her meals kylie cites
often ordering in
sushi mainly things like sashimi or
spicy avocado tuna on a rice cake which
sounds pretty awesome and i think that
sushi and sashimi
are just inherently really nutritious
takeout options
you know we've got some protein and
healthy omega-3 fats from the fatty fish
like tuna and salmon we've got carbs in
the rice
typically though the only veg that
you'll see in a sushi order
is like that sad iceberg lettuce salad
that they give you
as a side for your meal so to bump up
the fiber in your sushi dinner when you
are ordering
i would recommend opting for brown rice
whenever it's available
getting at least one veggie roll with
things like cucumber and avocado and
carrots and sea
vegetables and then ordering some
edamame or some sauteed
kind of garlic mushrooms on the side i
also recommend opting for really simple
nigeria sashimi or mackie instead of the
really elaborate ones that
are typically packed with tempura bits
and mayo based sauces and things like
that
also i suggest leaning more on things
like wasabi and ginger to flavor your
sushi
rather than soaking it in soy yes low
sodium
soy sauce is a better option than
regular but it still has 22 percent of
your sodium needs per tablespoon
and if you are clumsy with your
chopsticks like i am
it is not hard to just like really get
her soaked i am
definitely not a sushi connoisseur but i
assume if you ask someone who was
they would probably say that if if it is
quality fish
and it probably should be if you're
willing to eat it raw simple
is always best kylie also mentions her
drink choices so she's into corona light
which brings back some unsavory memories
in cancun
also white wine or just like straight up
shots
i mean again i'm not gonna shame any mom
or anyone else for wanting a drink
because
i get it but i'm also not going to
legitimize the health halo
some types of booze like wine is often
given
so my take home on drinking what i call
balanced boozing
is to choose the drink that you enjoy
the most whether that's beer or wine or
spirits
and enjoy it in moderation i
lock myself in my bedroom and
i turn on my tv i get really comfortable
and i pre-slice
an apple find my bed since i'm really
comfortable i'll be too lazy
probably to go down to the kitchen so
i'm gonna
my only choice is this apple so that is
how
i swerve my late night cravings
yeah that is problematic
if you need to lock yourself or a food
up
to prevent yourself from eating then
it's time to really re-evaluate
how you're feeding yourself in the day
an
apple can of course be a great bedtime
snack but
if you're actually wanting popcorn or
toast or
anything else and the only reason that
you're not eating those things is
because you're stuck in your room
you're either a restricting these
forbidden foods and therefore finding
yourself
in a state of mental scarcity b
restricting food in general and are
physically deprived of calories
or c all of the above
so while we are hearing about some fun
foods and kylie's routine like
doritos burgers and beer my sense is
that
these are things that she likes and
wants to eat
but clearly doesn't allow herself to eat
often enough
if she did she wouldn't need to
forcefully limit herself to just
an apple before bed and she also
wouldn't need an official
cheat day to get it all in
so folks i'm sure i probably offended
some of my die hard kardashian fans out
there but
this review was all in fun and it was in
no way intended to critique
kylie personally or professionally in
fact
i have mad respect for a 23 year old
woman
worth a whopping 900 million dollars
i also can say very little about what
kylie eats regularly
or even on like one day since
i'm just going off of this commentary
style harper bazaar video
but if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see me review more of these
harper bazaar clips
please like this video leave me a
comment below on who
i should check out next until then don't
forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that little bell so you never
miss out on a video
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye